hello everyone welcome to the minescape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll in
various conversations both here on the
podcast and elsewhere out there in what
you might think of as the real world
i've noticed that the topic of
extraterrestrial life life on other
planets elsewhere let's just say in our
galaxy is one that engenders very strong
emotional reactions people feel very
strongly about this topic about whether
or not such life exists about whether or
not it will be technologically advanced
whether it be friendly whether it will
be like us or something completely
different which when you think about it
is funny i mean why should you have such
emotional reactions about something
about which we know so little about
which there is so little data i think
that it's okay i mean as a good busy and
you're going to have priors about the
likelihood of certain things but you
shouldn't be so confident one way or the
other
i have my own beliefs you know i think
that it's actually unlikely that in our
galaxy there are other
very advanced technological
civilizations out there um if i didn't
know anything if i didn't have any data
at all i would think that might be very
likely there are a lot of planets out
there after all but if there were
technologically advanced civilizations
it would be very easy to have noticed
them already and we haven't now maybe
they're hiding or whatever perfectly
possible but it's just easiest to
imagine they're just not there but again
we should be open-minded i could be
completely wrong about this when it
comes to what life is going to be like
again we know very little it's certainly
very plausible that life is ubiquitous
but it's just single-celled or extremely
primitive in all sorts of ways if life
does become complicated if you get
eukaryotic or the equivalent
multicellular life in a variety of
different configurations what are those
organisms going to be like they're going
to be somehow like humans are going to
be star trek aliens that like have
humans but rubber faces or will it be
something completely different i've
generally been on the side of thinking
life will be something completely
different just because again what are
our imaginations supposed to tell us
about these things it's just too easy to
be swayed by our experience with life
here on earth better i would think to be
very very open-minded about the
possibilities for something growing up
somewhere completely different but again
it's important to listen to the views on
the other side so on today's podcast we
have ari kirschenbaum who's a zoologist
at the university of cambridge in the uk
usually he studies how various kinds of
animals communicate to their uh versions
of language and so forth but he's
written a fun new book the zoologist's
guide to the galaxy so what he's doing
is using his zoology training and
general biological knowledge to imagine
what life on other planets especially
advanced life might really be like and
he takes the opinion again not very
strongly he's being very reasonable but
he wants to raise the possibility that
despite our complete lack of knowledge
and the openness of the possibilities we
have learned a little bit from how
evolution works here on earth
to say that maybe life will be kind of
like us
the basic idea being that even though we
only have life on earth life on earth is
complicated there's a lot of it a lot of
different niches a lot of different
competitions for survival and under
different circumstances and what we see
over and over again is evolutionary
convergence to certain forms there are
also constraints from physics and
biology and energetics and chemistry
that make certain configurations more
plausible and more rewarding and more
reproductively successful there are
reasons why organisms tend to be
bilaterally symmetric have four legs
very often the advanced ones be a
certain size have a brain etc so arik
uses these kinds of considerations to
say you know maybe it's more likely than
not that the aliens are going to be
somewhat like us again not it's not
going to be star trek okay sorry about
that it's not going to be vulcans it's
not just going to be the ears going to
be more different than that but maybe
they won't be that different and we even
go in a little bit to talking about how
aliens could communicate in their social
organizations and whether or not they
will be friendly and again he tries to
at least put the idea into your head
that there's some optimism that aliens
will not be completely 100 alien after
all i think it's very important stuff to
think about because i still want to find
the aliens out there and i hope that
they're friendly even though i suspect
they're not out there and i worry very
much about them not being friendly so
let's go
[Music]
all right kirschenbaum welcome to the
mindscape podcast wow thanks for
inviting me
let me start with the classic
rewind the tape thought experiment right
this is a steven j gould i think
famously said that if you had started
evolution again
back from the beginning and let it go
there's enough kind of random
fluctuations that would something that
we would end up with something that
looked completely different than what we
have uh in the ecosystem right now so
yes or no is that is that true
well it's it's the kind of question that
that's that's uh i don't know i don't
think people really really take it quite
the way that it was that it was meant
that he that he initially meant
obviously things are going to be
different so much of earth's history it
has been dependent on contingencies and
and random chances and asteroids strikes
and and things like that the idea that
things will be exactly the same it
clearly isn't right
um
but the question is are we going to get
are we going to get some of the same
processes some of the same results that
that that that we did when in in real
life and it seems the answer's got to be
yes right we've got to have the same
kind of stuff and there's a whole bunch
of reasons why
that is the case why we would expect
that if evolution was to start again and
go through everything again we would
still expect to see you know four-legged
creatures and six-legged creatures and
eight-legged bridges and things like
that
and the main reason and the sort of
simple reason
is that a lot of the solutions that life
finds or that life can use are really
really heavily constrained
and there's very little that's that's
that's more heavily constrained than
constrained by physics right so legs
right legs
how do you move on a solid surface
you've got to have some friction
otherwise you can't exert a force you
really don't want to have much friction
because that you don't want to use too
much energy so so legs just seem to be
this great solution and they've they've
evolved so many times because there
aren't a whole load of of of ways to do
it
now when you come to legs it's an
interesting interesting example because
there are actually a few different kinds
of legs on earth
and um if you look at starfish for
instance they have really really really
interesting legs they're not solid legs
they're not even fixed legs right there
lots of little holes in there in their
shell and they and they exude part of
their insides out to form a little sort
of stubby leg and they can have hundreds
of these legs
so there are other solutions to what we
recognize as legs
but you notice that that
the kinds of jointed legs
that have become really successful in
insects and the crustaceans and the
vertebrates legs that you can
use as a lever you can pull one part of
the leg with a muscle they're just much
more efficient
now
given that that these are these are
really really efficient really effective
solutions if we were to rerun evolution
again would they would they occur
i suppose they might not by chance
but given enough time they're so
advantageous you know it's going to
happen
well we're ultimately going to try to
extend this reasoning to think about
what aliens are going to look like but
life is going to look like on other
planets um but we're constrained by only
having the one data point here right
here on earth so
is there some extent to which different
periods of time in biological history
count as different data points like can
we think about what niches were filled
and with what uh solutions back in the
dinosaur age and in other ages and then
sort of got wiped out uh and and learned
that in fact things do find similar
solutions
well the first thing i've got to say
i've got to say that when we find life
on other planets and we will and we'll
we'll find life soon
it's going to be slime right it's it's
just going to be like bacterial slime
the vast majority of planets that we
discover with life will be very simple
life
and you just need to look at earth's
evolutionary history how long it took
for complex life to evolve you realize
if you were to choose a point at random
in earth's history you'd find a lot of
green slime around and not much else so
so
yeah looking back at earth's history you
can see that there were periods when
well life was was simple what i call
simple it's of course incredibly complex
these single-celled organisms are
actually unbelievably complex and their
biochemistry is incredibly complex the
genetics is incredibly complex
but compared to life on earth today and
specifically compared to the diversity
of the ecosystem today
it was a very very very simple world
um
and but to come back to your question
can we use these different eras to to to
to treat them almost independently um
and to say well this gives us a clue
about about one aspect of how how life
evolves this gives us a clue to another
i'm i think you can to an extent i think
that there is a there is an argument
there
and that's because
i'm sure we'll come back to this again
again what drives evolution
what drives evolution
is ecosystems
right you don't think of this most
people don't think of this most people
don't realize this people think of
evolutions like survival of the fittest
and stuff like that which it is
but
fitness
and difference in fitness only comes
about because of complex ecosystems
sure you could have a world you know
that it's a bit hotter here and a bit
colder here and you hear it you get you
get some physical uh some physical
differences in in different places you
get added patient to physical
environment but pretty much all the
diversity we see on earth is because of
interaction with other organisms
and so the more complex an ecosystem
becomes
that's when you start seeing these
really complex innovations and you won't
see them in a simple ecosystem
so in other words there were flying
dinosaurs in some sense uh can we think
about
that as sort of a prediction you could
have made ahead of time you say well you
know it's going to be a lot of dinosaurs
there'll be a lot of different kinds of
life there's a niche out there for
flying creatures and chances are
life will find a way to make that happen
or is that too simplistic
well
flight is obviously a really useful
thing assuming you know assuming that
you live in a on a planet that's got a
solid surface and a and probably a a
gaseous atmosphere
don't forget flying is really really
common in the ocean right the fish fly
um there's no real there's no real
physical difference between a fish
flying and a bird flying except that the
fish has has
close to a neutral buoyancy so if it
stops swimming it won't fall and and get
squashed on the ground um but actually
aerodynamically hydrodynamically they're
very similar processes but let's let's
talk about gas atmospheres
um yeah it's really useful uh to be able
to to move above the ground and we've
seen flight evolve on earth at least
four times
at least four times
all four times uh they're in groups that
have
jointed limbs
um so
birds bats pterosaurs uh extinct
pterosaurs and of course insects
but you've got to be able to
have
quite a you've got to be able to to flap
your wings essentially all four evolved
with wings that's not to say there's no
other way to fly but all four times on
earth they evolved with wings and with
and with to some extent flapping wings
um because you need support you know you
need you need levers that you can that
you can attach muscles to and make your
wings flat so so to some extent you
could predict
that if flight is going to evolve again
it will evolve in an organism with a
skeleton either inside or outside i
wouldn't expect jellyfish to fly and i
wouldn't expect them
you know i wouldn't expect the worms to
fly for instance
um so there are constraints like that
whether it would specifically be those
those dinosaurs that evolved into the in
into all the birds that we have today
that's that's kind of a harder
prediction to make
okay fair enough uh good enough for the
earth there's earth sust uh would you
like to move on to other planets now
you've already made this dramatic claim
and i've let you get away with it but
let's dig into it but we're going to
find life we're going to find life soon
uh
i hope that's true but i'm certainly
convinced that's true i mean certainly
it would fit the data if
life on earth was the only life in the
observable universe right so what gives
you the conviction that we're going to
find it soon
i'm not sure that it would fit the data
um and certainly certainly when we look
at the estimates current estimates of
how many earth-like planets there are in
the galaxy i'm not even talking about
planets at all i'm just talking about
earth-like planets yep you know current
estimates are between 10 and 40 billion
now
that's that's a lot of opportunities for
life for life to arise and i i mean
another point that that people forget um
which is worth making which is that
earth is in is really the environment of
early earth was not particularly unusual
and not particularly unusual chemically
or
in terms of the other environmental
conditions so there's we've got no
reason to believe that
the origin of life on earth was was
due to some set of very unusual
circumstances people forget how common
water is in the universe i mean water is
really common in the universe um so it's
not really all that surprising that
we've got
life that's that's that's based on water
so
i think that the numbers game
really strongly uh
indicates that that what's happening on
earth was not something was not
something exceptional
the optimism
of finding
life on other planets uh in the near
future uh
yeah you could probably argue well okay
there's life on other planets but it's
so rare that we're gonna struggle to
find it um
and i i tend to
to lean towards the towards the more
optimistic side origin of life is not my
not my field
um although of course i you know i
listen in as i pass by rooms in in the
corridor but but you know we've made a
lot of progress about about thinking
about different ways
that reproducing molecules could arise
um and and i think that that the sort of
consensus at the moment is that this is
not an unusual thing this is not
something that that's outrageous or
outrageously unlikely so i think when
you put those two things together
i don't think it's an unreasonable
hypothesis that life's going to be
widespread
i know i certainly agree with that and i
don't want to dwell on this because this
is not exactly as you said your area we
have talked with people whose area it is
but uh there's a lot of planets out
there that are earth-like i get that i
just think that we have no idea right
now what the chances are that any one
planet would develop life uh maybe it's
0.9 maybe it's 10 to the minus 100 i i
just don't know but let's imagine that
it happens so there's slime all over the
place we have to quickly jump uh because
we want to get to the you know more
advanced life so maybe say something
about this uh bottleneck that appears to
be there going from single-celled
organisms to multicellular organisms
yeah and of course life on earth existed
for well most of its most of its history
without the the existence of complex
multicellular organisms and when they
did when they did arise
it took it took a while right it took a
problem well we don't know of course but
it probably took a couple hundred
million years before
multicellular life really became
something like what what we recognize
now
and
one of the
interesting hypotheses and it's really
just a hypothesis but it's very
appealing one is that um these couple
hundred million hundred million years of
of
early multicellular life
in what we call the precambrian so
before we really have a lot of fossils
these were very simple ecosystems very
simple ecosystems so you had detritus
feeders you had organisms that fed on so
organisms fed on dead organic material
perhaps
we know there was some grazing going on
we know that there were organisms that
that ate algae and things like that we
do have some fossils of that but
essentially was it appears to have been
a world without much in the way of
predation as we understand it now
and the cambrian explosion so this this
event 540 million years ago where all of
a sudden uh we see
fossils of all kinds of basically of all
the the forms of life that we see now uh
all the progenitors of all the different
major branches of life we see now and a
lot that have gone extinct of course
these suddenly appeared
and people speculate you know is this
because of a chemical change in the
environment and
or
some kind of temperature change
and no doubt the trigger was one of
those
but that's not why
that diversity exploded that diversity
exploded because
new niches became available because new
interactions became available because
organisms had to
uh live their lives differently they had
to
run away when someone was coming to eat
them they had to burrow in the sand they
had to grow a shell so that so that they
wouldn't be eaten they had to grow teeth
so that they could eat other organisms
eyes so they could find food and so on
and so
really that all of these adaptations the
spikes and the and the and the
the shells and
and the huge complexity of the cambrian
the cambrian fossils
derives from the complexity of those
interactions between the organisms you
don't evolve these things for the sake
of it you know you follow these things
because they give you an advantage
um yeah so so
that really was the big that was the big
transition now whether that's an
inevitable transition uh seems likely
okay i mean people have certainly made
the case that how long
can a world without predation exist
that is essentially an unstable it's an
unstable system you know unstable but it
for a couple hundred million years is
pretty stable
but sooner or later someone's going to
take a bite out of someone else and then
all bets are off
i like that i think that that'll be the
the motto for the podcast sooner or
later we could take a bite out of
someone else and i'll bet throw off so
i mean it's interesting because it's
clear that in both cases the transition
from non-life to life and from
single-celled organisms to multi-cell
organisms there always was this
possibility this prospect of greater
complexity and all these niches being
filled but it did take a while uh for it
to catch on but i guess
both the existence here on earth of both
transitions gives us hope or the idea
that
ultimately life will get there right i
mean that if you give it enough time
enough space
life is going to find these interesting
complex ways to thrive
yeah the the sort of the rationale
behind that um
and
and i think this is this is a fairly
fairly well supported idea the rationale
behind that is that natural selection um
one not being a very efficient process
very inefficient process um
but it is quite a thorough process so if
a niche is available uh given enough
time you would expect an organism to to
discover that niche um and and that's
why
an unstable system such as one where no
one eats anyone else
seems unlikely to be able to persist in
the long term because really sooner or
later there will be some kind of some
kind of um
mutation some kind of of a
sequence of of events that leads
organisms to to rather than to making
their own food or eating what they find
on the ground to exploit other organisms
and and that's that's really a feature
of of natural selection that it does
tend to find those niches if they are
available
yeah
speaking of which the last big
transition that i just want to get on
the table is intelligent life
uh
what can we say about the idea of the
inevitability
from a natural selection point of view
that once life becomes complex enough to
be multicellular it will discover the
mechanism of intelligence of you know
gathering information about the world
and processing it in a non-trivial way
well i'm going to i'm i'm gonna make
stand here and say that i
i don't know what you mean by
intelligence but animals have been
intelligent ever since they've existed
okay right so 800 800 million years has
been intelligence
intelligence really is an ability to i
don't think we can come up with any
any robust definition other than an
ability to to
interpret the environment and and i
suppose you could say to integrate
different sensory inputs so if you just
respond reflexively to one input you
might not call that intelligence but but
essentially animals have been
intelligent since since they've existed
when we talk about intelligence when
people talk about intelligence
particularly when people talk about
alien intelligence
they tend to mean intelligence like us
and even that is not a very easy thing
to pin down how long has there been
intelligence like us
um so
really the the the driver as we
understand it now and this is this is
still a
field of active research and and quite
contentious really but as we understand
now human intelligence the sort of thing
that that we would look at in an alien
and say oh yeah they're intelligent like
us
is probably driven almost exclusively by
social
requirements
so we are intelligent
because we had complex societies our
ancestors lived in complex societies
and you know they needed to keep track
of who
who
worked with them yesterday and who who
annoyed them yet the day before
yesterday and who they should who they
should cooperate with now to form an
alliance against this one and that this
kind of complex social processing seems
to be
something different
from
the intelligence that you see in a lot
of other species any species can
be trained
using very simple very simple training
techniques to perform clever tasks yeah
clever stuff yeah all animals can do
that chickens can do that
bees can do that
you can use you can use operant
conditioning to train just about
anything to do just about anything
but this kind of social intelligence
seems to be much rarer
and i think that that's uh
so that would seem to be i'm not sure
that it's a phase transition um
i think it feels like a phase transition
to us
because of the way we've altered the
world
yeah um
rather than because of the nature of the
intelligence itself and there are of
course other
intelligent social animals on the planet
many of whom have been around for a lot
longer than us
they just
haven't done the damage that we've done
and so you might not have recognized
that as as being a phase transition
i guess that it
raises another question that i i hadn't
thought about explicitly but um i
completely am on your train as far as
we've been intelligent as far as long as
there have been animals but there's some
kind of intelligence that we have in
mind specifically when we're thinking
about aliens we're going to ask about
the ability to develop technology right
that's that's something that we're going
to care a lot about
i mean what is the lesson we learn from
the fact that here on earth there are
uh different species that are
intelligent in different ways and yet uh
human beings are the ones who came up
with the ability to build machines and
so forth
and and the the standard answer there is
a standard answer uh the standard answer
is language
um of course that's a cop-out answer
because why did humans involve language
um
hasn't actually answered any any
question uh but there does seem to be
uh
our technological ability does seem to
be linked to language and you could
imagine you could argue
persuasively i think that an intelligent
technological alien civilization must
have a language right you're going to
build a spaceship you've got to say to
someone hey pass me the screwdriver
whatever you know you've got to have
some way of
of communicating um so so language seems
to be
very
closely
very closely involved in this the
trouble is we don't really know why
language evolved we don't have a really
good handle on what it was
what happened that caused this this
very this this really was phase
transition
from whatever our ancestors
however they communicated and i'm sure
they they communicated well
but that that jumped to to the ability
to convey an unlimited number of
concepts and just to invent concepts and
convey them
we don't have a good idea
how that happened but i think i think
that's got to happen
for for truly technological civilization
to arise and just be clear when you say
language means something much more
specific than communication all animals
communicate but you mean something more
symbolic and abstract and and the
ability to generate all sorts of
different ideas yeah the definition of
languages is also really contentious and
and different people from different
disciplines will give you different
definitions i've got a very simple
definition it's the ability to
communicate an unlimited number of
concepts
so we know
uh from studying animal communication
sometimes very complex it's never
anywhere close never close to conveying
an unlimited number of concepts that
really does seem to be a purely human
purely human thing now how that ties
into abstract concepts uh how that ties
into to i to predicting the future and
imagining the future
different people have a lot to say about
this you know
to what extent is our ability to um
imagine ourselves in the future to what
extent is that really tied to our
language people used to think this was
this was essential you know if you don't
have a language you can't you you can't
make that that kind of mental leap um
there are some animals that appear to
have that ability to greater a lesser
extent but certainly none of them have
have languages as i would define it
yeah we had a previous podcast guest
malcolm macgyver uh who studies
the transition from life in the water to
life on land and he thinks that that was
actually the first transition that
started animals on the road to imagining
the future long before
there was language but that's an
interesting connection that i hadn't
thought of myself so
what i want to ask you is
again to be very very specific because
you
you just made the claim that only human
beings have this ability to
generate infinite number of concepts
through language so we're making a claim
about
the intelligence of you know dolphins
and octopuses and and so forth they can
have
in some sense very high
intelligence but they don't and they
talk in complicated ways
but without this sort of infinite
possibility space the language gives us
is that and this is your area so this is
something i can ask
yeah that's right and that's uh
that is what we think at the moment um
obviously we could could be surprised in
the future i don't think so there are a
number of reasons to think um that's
that's not the case and
one of the most important reasons that
we've got to put on the table right at
the beginning is that
you know animals are not trying to be
human animals are not evolving so that
they can become more like human and it's
really easy i think to slip into this
idea well dolphins dolphins are
intelligent right and dolphins are cute
and they communicate a lot so why
shouldn't they have language like us why
should they have language like us
actually um you know what
in what way are we the pinnacle of of um
of what evolution should be doing we're
clearly not
um dolphins have a communication system
that suits them very very very well
and it's not really on us to to kind of
prove that they don't have language we
would need to prove that they have some
need for language
um
and and all the evidence certainly is
that that they don't and
you know one of the best pieces of
evidence
is that they don't build spaceships and
and you know and and write books and and
things like that uh because
they would only evolve a language
if they had a need to do these things
and they don't have that need and
therefore they don't so so i think even
when you look at um
you know chimpanzees and and dolphins
and all of these
these species that you think well these
are the these are the top communicators
parrots parrots are very another very
interesting another very interesting
species they
what they appear to have
is a certain linguistic ability so
there's no doubt that they have a
certain linguistic ability if you think
of alex the parrot i don't know if
you've heard of of um alex the paradise
african grey parrot who who really
did learn to speak
in a way that that we understand you
know to understand how sentences are
constructed and and really to understand
the concepts that that he was conveying
parrots don't do that in the wild right
um so so what we were seeing was an
underlying linguistic ability the
certain linguistic ability
there probably several species have
but they don't use it they don't use it
for language if they did we would see
that you know you would see all these
parrots flying around and talking to
each other
but but they don't
is it possible to pinpoint this is
probably an overly ambitious question
but uh
even if we don't know when it happened
what happened
to give human beings the capacity for
language was it and what did we invent
was it grammar was it uh you know uh
concatenating different ideas in
different ways you know what was that
kind of transition
yeah it's it's really hard to say it's
really hard to say
language doesn't fossilize um and
you know you can look a little bit at
the at the evolution of the of the vocal
tract to get fossils of
of of that you could say oh well at this
time maybe
humans evolved to have more control over
the of the sounds that they produce but
the kinds of questions you're asking
about grammar
and about recursion and about the the
the structure of of the language itself
very very very contentious very hard to
answer i think if we're going if we're
going with the the sort of accepted
consensus at the moment that
language evolved as a as a byproduct of
the complex social
interactions um
then then probably you could say that
the the the big step was could have been
something like uh the need to
communicate social information from from
one to another so if you look at
chimpanzees today um clearly
a very complex hierarchical social
system with a lot of intrigue going on
and a lot of alliances and a lot of
shifting alliances and but you could
kind of imagine if you if you have close
your eyes and squint you know you could
kind of imagine that it would be useful
for one chimp to say to another one how
about we gang up on on such and such
tomorrow um and and that would seem to
be the the kind of of trigger that that
could lead to to a more complex language
so in some sense uh the hypothesis would
be that it's you know the desire to
make a contract or a bargain that uh is
driving us for this abstract notion of
language to say if you do this i will do
that right to speak subjunctively
that's the hypothesis that's very much a
hypothesis i'm not sure how you would
test it um but but yeah
no problem when i do for a living just
feel anything we don't get tested but
someday we we were hopeful
one other thing i want to get on the
table though is you know language is a
natural thing to emphasize when moving
toward technology in terms of alien
civilizations but what about just the
classic role of opposable thumbs right
you know i mean is there an argument
that dolphins don't have technology
because they don't have a ability to
hold a hammer
so
as an evolutionary biologist i would
reverse that
and i would say that
dolphins don't need to use a hammer
that's why they don't have possible
farms
so
there are many ways to manipulate the
environment
i don't think any of us would be
particularly surprised if we discovered
technological octopus-like aliens um you
know there's no reason to think it has
to be uh through
uh through opposable funds i mean i know
that that goes against what i was saying
previously about levers
levers are important
um and i think that
that
on any on any complex and any planet
with a complex ecosystem you would still
expect to find animals that use those
levers to move around
but for manipulation
yeah you know you could imagine
something like a starfish with with
hundreds of little hundreds of little
stubby fingers uh
turning a screwdriver i don't think
opposable thumbs is the opposable thumbs
is one of those things we've picked on
yeah that humans in the past have picked
on to show how different we are from
other animals it doesn't seem to be very
fundamental really
that's perfectly fair but but good this
is getting us directly into the question
of what aliens are going to be like when
we meet them and we say hi uh i mean it
seems to me that
the specifics of human anatomy or human
evolutionary history uh have been shaped
by the fact that
life first flourished in the ocean but
we live in the air on the ground right
we're lucky enough to have a planet that
has a lot of water surface but also a
lot of land surface do we expect that uh
i mean the fact that we don't live
underwater seems to have been important
for our development as a technological
civilization do we expect that aliens
are going to live on land also do you
think
um
i think there's
there's clearly advantages to living on
land right
fire for instance
harnessing harnessing energy uh could be
a bit difficult under water but but that
doesn't again natural selection
will tend given enough time to find
solutions and and there there may well
be many solutions to uh energy sources
underwater that
simply haven't haven't been discovered
on earth because the chemical and
physical
conditions aren't aren't uh unsuitable
so i'm not too
i'm not
too obsessed with the idea that it that
there must be land-based um intelligent
life i mean one of the major targets of
investigation of extraterrestrial life
forget about these billions of of
exoplanets they're the moons of jupiter
and saturn in our own solar system which
have large underground oceans now um if
life is flourishing in those in those
large underground oceans could it evolve
to be
technological possibly um i can't
immediately think what that would look
like i wouldn't want to speculate what
it would look like but it certainly
doesn't sound
certain it doesn't sound impossible i
mean it does raise a huge question
about what people like creatures like
yourself would do um how would you be an
astronomer in a you know in an
underground ocean um
but presumably someone will come along
and speculate well where are we you know
what's the other side of this of this
great ice and that that's um that's
above us and and and one could imagine
that that such technology and such
culture
could arise
um one thing that that though because
you asked about about our specific
anatomy
one point that that i really want to
make that's really important is you can
think about you know if you think about
the pioneer plaques and and these ideas
of of
an engraving of of two humans waving and
and like oh is this going to mean
anything really to an alien who receives
this and they're going to look at it are
they going to notice immediately that
that's what we are
well i think there's a pretty good
chance of that actually because one of
the characteristics of our biology
is that we're bilaterally symmetrical
we've got a left side and a right side
and actually almost all
animal life on earth is bilaterally
symmetrical a few that aren't corals and
jellyfish and things like that but but
basically the advantages of bilateral
symmetry in terms of moving it's just so
much more effective so much more
efficient to move when you have a left
side and right side you also have a
front and a back
means that that
we bilaterians as we're called have
absolutely swept the planet taken over
and that happened in the ocean it did
not happen on land um
so so there's another there's another
feature another seemingly peculiar
feature of our biology that would appear
to be
very very advantageous and probably
widespread so you know the aliens will
look at this engraving of a human and
say well that that's a picture of
something that's got a left side and the
right side that could be an organism i
totally see that happening
we do have a lot of machines that also
have left sides and right sides
right and then but this is now we're
we're sort of drifting into a into a new
question
of
what about technologically created life
and many people have speculated that
when we find life in the universe it's
going to be technological
and you know there are arguments there
are arguments in favor of that
for one thing
life has limited
has a limited existence you know species
go extinct eventually and you could
imagine that that over enough time a
civilization that becomes technological
will create
artificial intelligent robots and and so
on and they will persist they will
persist much longer than biological
organisms could so this is an argument
that people have made
um
and and
i find it slightly unconvincing argument
actually um but but
yeah we have machines that are
bilaterally symmetrical like cars
but they're not re they could couldn't
be confused for life
um perhaps in another couple hundred
years we'll have
life-like
machines um and perhaps other
civilizations have already developed
them but we don't appear to have them
yet
let me go back to the underwater life uh
question just just to finish up one
thought because
it really highlights this difficulty we
have that we only have our example of
life here on earth right because
it's you raise a very very good
problem for underwater life that you
can't make fire right um
tool use is kind of primitive there's
some tool used i guess uh among
underwater organisms but not that much
um so i guess how safe are we in
extrapolating
facts like that i mean you i think
correctly
cautiously say well maybe they could
figure it out but i can't guess how they
could figure it out and and is it
possible that we stumble across a
universe full of oceans
with complex life inside and none of
them have uh built a computer
and and that that really is um that
really is starting to to go
so far along the the lines of
speculation
that um that it's hard to it's it's hard
to know
really whether we can say much in
that's concrete but i will illustrate
one point which is that
this is one of my favorite earth
organisms i mean i say favorite earth
i've got loads of favorite earth
organisms one of my favorite
illustrations using earth organisms
when you think about electric fishes so
there are these what are called weakly
electric fissures um not many a few
species um
that
use electric fields to communicate
now
almost no creatures on earth use
electric fields to communicate
quite a few use electric fields to sense
the world um
even some mammals do that but to
communicate they don't and there's a
number of reasons for that one is just
that it uses so much energy it takes so
so so much energy so you have to have
you have to have loads of energy at your
disposal or no alternative in case these
these officials they have no alternative
no other way of communicating um but it
also depends on the medium
right so you need a medium that will
that will transmit these electro these
electro electric waves um in such a way
that they can that they can be picked up
and and you know that's an advantage of
being in water
and not being on land so
so we're really quick to to to say well
there's loads of things you can't do in
water that you can do on land but then
here's someone who's communicating in
water in a way that you can't do on land
and we hadn't really thought of that and
there may be a lot of other examples
like that a lot of other technologies
that just could be more possible in
water than on land fair enough that's a
very very good point i i will think
about that but but okay let's with that
as a caveat in mind let's stick to um
animals that are on land
animal animal life is that even is it
fair to say that when we
are talking about
alien life the category of animals makes
sense is the division into animals and
plants and and uh protists or whatever
are these likely to be part of alien
biology
well it makes sense to me and that's and
i'm i'm striking out against convention
by saying that these aliens will will be
animals and and the reason is once upon
a time i mean when i was growing up and
you know you recognized animals by their
features the
movement and and
all kinds of characteristics of the
animals okay well an animal has these
these characteristics we don't do that
anymore um these days all biological
classification is done
by their phylogenetic tree by their
evolutionary relationships animals are
defined very simply as descendant all
the descendants of the ancestor of the
modern animals which was a little
unicellular creature that that lived in
the oceans whatever 900 million years
ago um
very closely related to the ancestor of
the fungi um but but an animal is simply
a descendant of of that creature so
that then becomes
a pointless definition
when you talk about alien life because
by definition no alien could be an
animal
well if
if you've excluded them by definition
then that's not very helpful so i would
then go back i i'm keen on going back to
the old definition or at least part of
the old definition
and saying what is an animal actually
well
in the context of of looking at alien
life an animal is an organism
firstly it's a heterotroph so it's an
organism that has to go out and get food
it doesn't make its own food it has to
go and get it and it's that going and
getting yeah that makes an animal an
animal so you know i think we could
we can say if we were
to come across a a planet with lots of
moving organisms
why are they moving
probably to find energy i mean this is
what life has to do
and that's really the the characteristic
of animals
yeah so no root systems no
photosynthesis you have to go out and
forage no i'm not not excluding the fact
that you could get a group-like creature
right that both photosynthesizes and
moves um there's no reason for that we
know symbiotic um symbiotic organisms
that that use they make use of other
organisms to do photosynthesis but
there's no real reason why my
photosynthesis should be excluded from
that um but that idea of no i gotta move
i've gotta move to get my food
really is what launched the animals on
on the path to the diversity we see
today yeah and you already mentioned
predation as a big part of that so the
picture i'm getting is you know once
animals develop the ability once life
develops the ability to walk around and
eat things uh we're launched on a path
to greater complexity and eventual
technological uh mastery so it wouldn't
be surprising again who knows but it
wouldn't be surprising if
intelligent alien life was something we
would recognize as animal-like
yes i would agree i would agree because
and
and
again science fiction writers have taken
issue with this but i'm gonna i'm gonna
stick with it um animals have to solve
time critical problems
uh whereas plants don't
so i i know there are different time
scales and you could argue well okay
plants solve time to solve problems over
a longer time scale
but they're still competing with animals
animals are living in the same ecosystem
and animals are working at a much
shorter time scale so so
you know when a plant solves a problem
that it faces with an animal it's
different from the way an animal solves
a problem with an animal you've got to
make decisions quickly
things are changing all the time
everything's moving around you your
food's moving away from you someone's
coming to eat you and and that really
appears to have been a strong driver of
the evolution of intelligence
good so far all right i'm with you here
uh so we go to the other planet we go to
alpha centauri and there's some planet
around there that has animals on it um
and now we're starting to get specific
so the animals live on land um and
you've already made a pitch for
bilateral symmetry
what about arms and legs and heads i
mean are these basic recognizable
features likely to also be part of alien
biology
well like i said if you're if you're
moving on a solid surface then then
limbs seem to be so efficient that that
you know it's just going to it's going
to be
um they're going to be the dominant life
form if everyone's running around trying
to eat each other if you've got legs you
can lift yourself off the ground then
then you've got a huge advantage now of
course there are many animals on earth
that have lost their legs things like
snakes right they exploiting a very
specific niche where legs would just get
in the way
but that's a specific niche the idea of
limbs
i think has been has been hugely hugely
successful and you know you can see from
the development of the arthropods of the
of the insects that the huge diversity
of insects is largely down to the fact
that they have
the
so many options for how what different
kinds of jointed appendages they can
have you can have legs you can have
wings you can have antennae and and and
that's really allowed them to to exploit
at such a such a wide range of niches
and this is this is what happens you
know when
when there's a lot of potential
variation in
the morphology of an organism
then you tend to get
a diversity of niches a diversity of
ways of exploiting the environment and
exploiting other other organisms
it's a good point because as you say
not every land-based creature has legs
but most of them do and there's sort of
some good reason and this is part of
your sales pitch right that there are
physics-based reasons for the specific
solutions that life has found to these
puzzles
well there are some physics-based
reasons yeah some of the constraints are
definitely in in the realm of physics
some of them are some of them are not so
many of the constraints are
more based on on the evolutionary
interactions between between organisms
but yeah a good starting point is is the
physics for sure
and okay
now just in the middle of this
conversation is the first time ever
thinking about this but
we even though so many organisms have
legs remarkably few have arms and hands
in some sense right
arguably some other primates i mean
definitely some other primates kangaroos
but you know most of the life forms that
come immediately to my brain use
all of their legs in a sort of similar
way
is that something we should uh be
surprised about or does that make sense
i'm not entirely sure that it's even
true i i know that i i certainly if you
if you think about mammals um
it's largely true but as you say the
primates are rodents used to use their
their pores to manipulate things uh if
you have seen a squirrel eating a nut
you know it's uh it's quite it's quite
common um birds have a bit of a problem
because they need two of their limbs to
fly with so so that doesn't leave them
very much flexibility in in that respect
um
and yeah i guess amphibians and um
and other some reptiles do but but i
think it's i think it's probably going a
bit far to say that most animals don't
use don't use their legs and insects
certainly do crabs i mean you know
crustaceans
um counter example i guess i'm just
thinking of i yeah
you're right there's a continuum i guess
um in human beings the roles of arms and
legs have just completely differentiated
in a way that
in a raccoon you're a squirrel they
still walk on all fours right um
how bold can we be when thinking about
the aliens to say
technologically advanced aliens are
likely to walk on two legs or will they
be like centaur-like having four legs
and two arms
what are the
constraints there from biology or
physics or whatever
well they have an even number i think i
think if they're bilaterally symmetrical
they have an even number and i think
that's that's a good thing that's a
place to start uh
the the transition to
bipedalism uh among humans is another
controversial uh issue just about
everything in human evolution is
controversial uh there are all kinds of
ideas about why humans developed
the ability to walk on two legs and a
lot of those ideas a lot of those
hypotheses have got to do with
manipulation so to leave your hands free
to to manipulate but there are plenty of
other ones you know so you can see above
the grass so you
you don't get as hot in the sun
loads and loads of explanations enough
explanation enough plausible
explanations
to make you think well
this doesn't seem to have been a
fundamental transition okay this this
really doesn't this seems to have been
something that that yes was crucial on
the path to our evolution because of the
specific situation that our ancestors
were in in a in a
in a forest world that was that was
rapidly being converted into grassland
for instance and then you know this was
this was just the way we needed to be we
needed to run faster to carry things you
know we needed to carry food from one
place to another because it wasn't just
any old tree that would have fruit in it
so that was very specific um to our
evolution and i don't think anyone has
any difficulty looking at a raccoon for
instance and saying well i can imagine a
raccoon
flying a spaceship and you know
we can right rocket no it's a perfect
example
i've seen it i've seen it on tv yeah um
okay very good uh
so i wonder i want to switch over to the
sort of social linguistic aspects of the
these wonderful thought experiments
we're doing but just to put a cap on it
um you know to what extent are there
laws of biology i mean uh i know there's
sort of scaling laws that we see in uh
different species here on earth uh we
have networks inside of us that seem
like a naturally efficient kind of
system that maybe that would also be the
case in aliens um
so are there laws are there right size
do we expect intelligent aliens to be
meters high rather than hundreds of
meters high or millimeters high i mean
what can we say about uh the
possibilities based there
there are laws um
and
and the laws tend to be
well the laws that we understand really
well are the laws of natural selection
we haven't spoken much about natural
selection and even my
my main premise which is that natural
selection is what will be driving
complexity on other worlds which some
people contest
but we understand the laws of natural
selection pretty well um we've got
pretty good models of how natural
selection works and how kinship
plays a role in natural selection and
and an important role
but you know when we do speculative
biology and and astrobiology and and so
on
we are constrained by our understanding
of
earth biochemistry
right so all a lot of the questions that
you asked about size and networks and so
on are to do with the biochemistry that
we understand on earth
and although as i said water is very
common in the universe and and amino
acids are dead easy to make and they're
probably everywhere and so it's very
likely that that alien life will be
based on a carbon chemistry somewhat
similar to ours
we don't we don't know that for sure
um and you can just think about some of
the recent
talk about life in the clouds of venus
for instance you know really chemically
extreme environments and and what kinds
of chemistries might might exist there
so i think it's it's hard to to
to be sure that the kinds of constraints
that
exist
because of chemical and and structural
constraints on earth would be the same
ones on on other planets but on the
other hand i wouldn't be surprised
either precisely because
because these chemicals are so common um
and and so reactive so i don't know i
don't think um
i don't think i would like to to
speculate on
on
size quite as much as as that but but
yeah within a couple order of magnitude
either way
probably a reasonable window
i guess i should have asked earlier more
about the biochemistry i mean obviously
life on earth as we know it is very very
uh dependent on this relationship
between dna rna proteins right in a very
very specific way and there's kind of
basic chemical reasons why i mean it
could be can we be so bold as to imagine
that that would be a feature of alien
life as well i mean dna is just such a
good molecule for sending information
down through generations there's really
no competitor to it or or might there be
that we just haven't thought of yet
well there's no competitor to it
that there is no competitor to it is no
real surprise we don't know whether dna
was the only or rna was the only form of
of life that evolved on earth um there
may well have been competing
biochemistries that have all gone
extinct
uh which you would expect if dna were
were a much more efficient way to to run
things so
we don't know that
people are trying to just to work on
these ideas but what we do know is that
it's not dna that's special okay that is
not what's special about life what's
special about life is the ability to
inherit
traits and and variation and and with
with uh
for
one generation to pass it straight on to
to to the next generation
that is what's essential for natural
selection um
must it been done through dna no
one could speculate and imagine all
kinds of other ways i can't because i'm
not a biochemist
and
i dare say that many of those ideas and
many of those alternatives have really
strong arguments against them in terms
of stability and energetic efficiency
and so on
um
but i i i wouldn't get too too caught i
don't get caught up on on the whole dna
thing because yeah there's certainly
there's got to be other other ways of
doing it
but some form of heritable information
is essential you know i
that's certainly my inclination but then
i have friends who are building
microscopic robots and computers
uh at the molecular level
and they're doing it out of dna and i
said you know why that's because there's
a lot of dna around and they say no it's
because it's just the right molecule to
do this it contains information and it
lasts a long time so i don't know maybe
some version of dna even if it's not
exactly like we have here on earth might
be uh common to alien environments
yeah and and
of course
although
they uh they don't actually use they're
not using dna because it's it's here and
it's available they're using it because
it's inspired them
um and if they had seen another molecule
that did something similar they would be
using that molecule um yeah to be fair
uh you did say one kind of um
provocative thing that i don't want to
let completely escape
the relationship between evolution
natural selection and complexity um you
know famously evolution is not
teleological it's not oriented toward
making things more complex but it has
happened that the
very complex organisms have arisen
through natural selection so you think
that that's a natural thing to have
happen and you seem to be implying that
not everyone agrees
no i think i i think that's um i think
people agree with the idea that natural
selection will tend to increase
complexity um i think that's um that's
uncontroversial i think i i've had
people say to me for instance how do you
know that natural selection is the force
driving life on other planets how can
you be sure we only have one example um
and that's that's an easier there's a
relatively easier argument to
dismiss um
largely probably the best argument in
favor of natural selection is it just
happens so easily um you know you really
don't need very much
for natural selection to to get going
you need to have this variation that's
heritable and you need to have some sort
of differential fitness some some
configurations that that are more
efficient than others and it just goes
uh it just goes all by itself so so
apart from the fact we can't think of
any other mechanism
which is perhaps a weak argument um
there's the argument that that natural
selection is just so easy to easy to to
set off so so it's it's going to be out
there sure yeah now that that i'm
completely willing to sign up for
um so good let's move into the
completely crazy speculative parts of
this question um
we have our bilaterally symmetric aliens
who might have legs and arms and things
like that how do they talk to each other
how do they communicate is it going to
be like the borg are they going to be a
collective intelligence uh do we have
reasons to believe that individuality is
a crucial part of uh
advanced technological civilizations or
is that just a little anthropocentric
well um communication of course it's
there everywhere uh all animals all
animals communicate plants communicate
and
it's important first of all the first
sort of
ground rule to lay down is that
communication always evolves from
sensing right all communication has
evolved from sensing sight
hearing everything everything we hear
because you know we we speak in in words
because we can hear it it's it's not the
other way around we didn't involve ears
to speak
and that's really key because that's one
of the reasons why there's no telepathy
um even if you could think of a physical
explanation of how telepathy could work
it wouldn't evolve it would never evolve
because there's no point in in in
sensing
brain waves if no one's transmitting any
brain waves and there's no point in
transmitting your brain waves if no
one's evolved the means to listen to
them
we evolved vision
because
we could use light to find food
irrespective of of of anyone
communicating we didn't involve vision
to see other people other people were
would were waving at us
we didn't involve hearing to hear other
people speaking we evolved hearing
because it helped us to detect movement
in in the water around us so so
communication evolves out of sensory out
of sensory
systems
what sensory systems work well
depends on the physical environment so
already mentioned electric field
planting is really rare on on earth but
there are conditions in which it could
be fantastically effective i mean it's
really it's a good way to communicate
you can put lots of information into it
and it's just and it travels long
distances with very little loss
it's a great way to communicate it's
just really expensive
now
light vision is of course
really common and sensing by by sight is
one is very very old very very ancient
ability and plenty of unicellular
organisms have have that ability as well
um so so vision is is a is a good
communication medium
if you live in a transparent medium
um
and
you know even if you live in transparent
medium again coming back to enceladus
and europa and things if you live in an
underground ocean
well there's no light um so are you
really going to generate light why would
you bother generating light if no one
can see anything it's hard to see how
light could evolve under those
circumstances i mean you can you can
imagine cases underwater volcanoes might
produce some light or something like
that but but but basically you need a
transparent medium
the other
interesting thing about light
is and again we're talking about the
scales that that that we that we believe
in our sort of size and a couple of
magnitude bigger or smaller is because
of the the wavelength of light it's kind
of useless when something's in the way
um it doesn't really go round things at
all
and so you could be hiding behind a bush
and no one can see you
which in itself drives a lot of of
course drives a lot of evolution a lot
of diversity and different ways of
hiding and different ways of finding uh
other animals that are hiding
but sound does do that
sound has a wavelength that's long
enough to travel around objects
and
it travels long distances and it carries
a lot of information and the fact that
we use
sound to speak right now is no
coincidence it's just a really really
really good way of communicating in the
kind of environment in which we live of
course if you go to mars it's got a very
thin atmosphere you're a bit stuck the
sound is not a great way to to
communicate there but
but these kinds of ideas are these
physical constraints on what
communication modality communication
channel will work
that's definitely another physical
constraint that that's going to apply
equally on on on any planet
i mean sound going around corners
clearly very useful i i agree with that
uh but not but we can imagine very
different environments like you said
thin atmospheres or on the other hand
what if it was just a very noisy
environment so it's hard to rise above
the noise i'm kind of intrigued now by
the idea of using
light
in the way that you and i use sound so
not only to see things but to generate
it like glowing and sending signals that
way i mean that'll be an intriguing way
for aliens to talk to each other by
beaming signals at each other
yes except the other the other problem
with the wavelength of light the short
wavelength of light is that it is
actually very hard to detect it
so
when you think about how we detect sound
we have a frequency analyzer in our ears
so we have
a series of hairs of different different
thicknesses and lengths and they respond
differently to different wavelengths of
sound and that's why we can hear sound
uh in great great great detail
although we tend to think of of our
vision as being very acute it's very
acute spatially so we can tell that this
we can distinguish two points that are
close together very well because we have
lots and lots of light detecting uh
cells in our in our eyes but we're
really bad at detecting frequencies i
mean all we can do is is put colors you
know color filters in and and look at
the red green and blue
we don't have a system and
it's hard to imagine a system
um that would detect light by by its
frequency in the same way that we detect
sound by its frequency
so we think that aliens are going to
talk
i think that i think that that sounds a
really i think that sound is going to be
a really common way of communicating and
i got to say one thing right everything
that i say
it's quite likely that we'll find a
counter example somewhere in in the
universe right weird things are going to
happen but they're going to be really
rare
they're going to be rare the obvious
solutions are going to be really common
and and yeah sure we'll we may find
something that i don't know hasn't
evolved through natural selection well
maybe not that but some strange stuff's
going to be out there but
almost all the stuff that we find is
going to be very straightforward you
know if you're living in a in a dense
gas atmosphere you'll use sound to
communicate yep absolutely in a sense
because of the combination of the fact
we all live in the same physical world
plus the fact that natural selection
looks for good solutions you know we
will find good solutions over and over
again yeah natural selection finds good
solutions doesn't look for it
but okay we skipped over the
individuality versus collective question
i mean this seems to be a big question
to me we're very very used to life
taking the form of individual organisms
is that a blinkered parochial point of
view that we have or is that another one
we should expect to be very common
well
here's a good example of
looking at human evolution and
we have to be cautious right we have to
ask ourselves are we being are we being
too anthropocentric like with the
bipedality are we gonna are we really
sure that's what's important but on the
other hand um as i said our ancestors
social primates complex social societies
probably
and what appears to have driven the
evolution of language and the evolution
of intelligence as we understand it
seems to have been conflict
right so the potential for conflict so
i've got to decide am i going to
cooperate with this this uh
member of my group or am i going to
fight with them and and who am i going
to cooperate with to to achieve my aim
so that kind of conflict
drives intelligence just in the same way
as problem solving drives intelligence
right you know or other animals that
that octopus that needs to open a jar to
get some food or something like that
it's problem-solving you don't need
intelligence if you don't have a problem
to solve
so if we go
with the idea that human intelligence
human language evolved because of
conflicts in
pre-human society
then that would tend to argue against a
society without individuals or society
of clones like like bees or termites or
something like that um
leading to that kind of intelligence
yeah
okay yeah interesting i mean the
conflict i kind of translate that in my
brain is just saying that
uh life is harsh
right like when conditions are tough
evolution needs to work harder to find
clever solutions to things is that an
oversimplification or is that basically
the right idea
i think if things are harsh then then
it's more likely that complex solutions
will provide a
an answer um so
more complex solutions are likely to
arise because they they will provide a
better way of of dealing with things um
so you could imagine you certainly could
imagine a colony of bees and and and
they can really only survive in their
environment if they cooperate more if
they exchange more information between
them um and and so they
they have to
they have to know exactly how to open
the flowers or something like that and
so they have to convey this information
to each other and so a kind of language
develops
one could hypothesize about a situation
like that however
you know clones cooperating
is a little bit different from
individuals cooperating
and the best example that we have is
multicellularity itself
right we are a collection each of us is
a collection of clones of of clone cells
cooperating extremely well communicating
great deal of information we think about
all the information that goes around our
bodies not talking about our brains just
our immune system and and so on so
that's an example of clones cooperating
um together to to achieve a complex
goal
is it the kind of um intelligence that
that we're looking for hmm seems to be a
bit different somehow doesn't it
it does but uh it's not going to stop me
from asking you know
which is um
families uh sexual reproduction you know
like how
again it's obviously a huge worry that
we're only seeing things through
human-colored glasses here but uh
sexual reproduction does seem to be a
really good solution to various
evolutionary problems uh you can imagine
how sexual reproduction leads to kind of
pair bonding situations you know
are we crazy to think that alien
societies might have
not the same but related kind of social
structures for those reasons
well
for one thing
reproduction is essential for natural
selection so reproduction of some sort
there's there's got to be
and
what's interesting if you take a sort of
very broad view of of kinship
then you don't need sexual reproduction
to have kinship so if i'm an e coli
that's just uh reproducing asexually
producing clones
with occasional mutation it's still the
case that i will be more closely related
to my immediate descendants than to my
distant descendants
so they're still kinship
even though there's not there's not
sexual reproduction or partners or
societies or anything and that kinship
still will play into
very important part of evolutionary
theory which is kin selection right so
you're more likely to to cooperate into
and to
sacrifice your own good for
those organisms that share
share much of your genome so we can seek
in selection happening even without
sexual reproduction we could in theory
see whole societies whole families
based on on kin selection without sexual
reproduction
but it seems unlikely it seems unlikely
because what we know about um about life
on earth we look at the diversity
of
asexually reproductive reproducing
organisms on earth and
some people will say that the diversity
of asexually reproducing organisms is
huge because there are
billions of different
species and subspecies and kinds of
genomes and but you know they're all
bugs right um
and they're all little bacteria or
something like that this is the
the phenotypic diversity is very very
very small the the diversity and form
and the diversity in niche
is actually quite small compared to
multicellular organisms so
so there's something going on there's
something going on in the way that
that sexual reproduction
which is very ancient on earth we
believe um the way that sexual
reproduction is playing into the the uh
niche diversity the diversity of roles
that the different organisms have and
and
mostly for multicellular organisms
sexual reproduction on earth
is down to dna
right it's down to dna got two parents
what can you do
um
does it need to be
that way no if if life is not based on
dna which you know you might think it it
must be but
if it isn't while or even actually
even if it is based on dna there are
there are ways of having having multiple
uh multiple parentage multiple
inheritance so so
some kind of sexual reproduction
appears to have helped to drive the
diversity of life on earth and like you
said there are evolutionary problems
that it overcomes problems about how you
get rid of of
disadvantageous genes and things like
that and there are all kinds of reasons
why we might expect sexual reproduction
to arise
it doesn't seem to be
it doesn't seem to be
unduly earth centric to think that that
some form of sexual reproduction will
arise on another planet or at least let
me put it this way
if we see a complex ecosystem on another
planet
chances are there will be sexual
reproduction you can't predict that it
will arise on any particular planet
but
with hindsight if you see if you see a
complex ecosystem it's hard to see how
that could arise purely from asexually
reproducing organisms
alrighty i mean we have to uh wind up i
know that you have a cut off so
with all of these considerations on the
table
i guess one thing we haven't mentioned
out loud is the fact that if we do
meet
alien civilizations they're likely to be
at an extremely different stage of
development than we are
and there's an ongoing debate about
whether or not we should even want
to meet them do you put ourselves out
there or is it is it too dangerous you
know like how how crazily far can we
extend these considerations to wonder
about the friendliness
or sociability of aliens where we do
ever meet them
well
i
i'm not concerned myself and that's for
a number of reasons one is that of
course
you can argue all you like about whether
or not to send messages to aliens but
we've been doing it for 100 years
without meaning to so
any alien civilization that has anything
like the technology necessary to come
and visit us already knows that we're
here
there's no hiding absolutely not we've
been looking for alien civilizations
with our primitive technology and
haven't found any but you could imagine
that that that anyone who's out there
who knows what they're doing would be
able to find us so so i i don't i think
the cat's out of the back
um
but on top of that
you know the chances of
actually having a some kind of of
technological solution for traveling
between stars is pretty slight
we don't know
there may be there may be solutions
there may be technologies that can do
this
but if there are technologies that will
allow an alien civilization to travel
from one star system to another they are
so technologically advanced
and they have so much energy at their
disposal
why would they bother harming us you
know our preconceptions and our on our
and our fears of alien civilizations are
entirely based
on human behavior and entirely based on
human colonialism where
we needed to go to another country to
take all the gold or or you know to take
all of the of the slaves because we
didn't have enough stuff
here but if you can travel from one star
to another you can make as much stuff as
you want you can make as much food as
you want and really planet earth isn't
giving you anything um there's no
the the colonialism in an interstellar
sense
doesn't even seem to to to be logical i
don't see what people would be wanting
from other planets if you can get there
you can make what you what you like
and then the third argument of course uh
slightly more depressing argument
is that it's not at all clear
that most
civic technological civilizations will
survive to that point
it's not clear that we will survive the
next couple hundred years um technology
seems to be highly highly damaging um to
civilization so
you can imagine that anyone has reached
that point that has managed to get over
all of the kind of disastrous social um
social plagues that we have here climate
change and wars and racism and
any civilization that can get past that
and survive to the point becoming
technologically advanced
they're probably pretty nice guys
i like that optimistic spin i'm not i'm
not sure that i'm
but i'm happy to uh to take it for the
moment i mean so okay last question then
you know if you had to bet
right i know there's no way of of uh
judging these things in the short term
but
do you think that there's a federation
of planets out there that uh will
someday hook up with or do you think
that it'll be mostly
worlds full of slime and uh will be the
alpha dogs
yeah i tend to think there isn't um i
tend to think that if there were
it would have been more obvious than it
is but i certainly don't discount uh we
haven't really looked very hard to be
honest our seti seti work has been
pretty uh pretty focused and and pretty
minimal we've covered a very tiny tiny
range of the of the possibilities so i'm
not sure um i tend to think there isn't
which is
which is disappointing because the
biggest disappointment to me as a
zoologist
is that i'm never going to see any of
these alien animals right we're never
going to travel to any of these planets
never going to be able to watch the only
hope the only hope that i have
is that somewhere out there there's an
alien david attenborough who's going to
be sending us
tv shows showing all of the animals on
their planet and that's that's that's
the only way we're going to find out
as long as we can figure out how to
build a a dvd player that works with
alien technology that'll be the tricky
part but
but i like the the
possibility of getting the shows from
the bbc alien bbc so ari kirkenbaum
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast thank you so much
[Music]
you